they were promised an easy way into
europe and paid hundreds of even
thousands of dollars for a dream that
quickly fell to pieces
it was on facebook and on social media
today says like
the border is free now of guards you can
cross it or something
together with his relative 17 year old
ali yasim from iraq is detained in a
camp in lithuania after crossing the
border from belarus they were picked up
with thousands of others by border
guards in recent months they tell us how
they could easily enter belarus and
received help to reach the lithuanian
border the gateway into the european
union
every people here said very sad children
and baby and woman
you ask this is in europe and they
were a woman coming here with children
in prison
in their prison why
because you're coming here because you
want it alive
lithuania recently started to push
people who showed up at the border back
to belarus in return belarusian troops
stopped them from re-entering on this
footage released by lithuanian border
guards a group of 35 iraqis are seen
stuck between the two sides
lithuania eventually allowed the
migrants in and accused the belarusians
from illegally crossing its border the
the playing deadly games with the human
rights lives
is unacceptable and has to be condemned
unfortunately
people
whom we consider to be victims in that
situation
are used by luka schenker regime as the
tool as a weapon against the european
union in general in particular lithium
because of its very strong political
position in an effort to stop the influx
of migrants and asylum seekers lithuania
has been constructing a barrier on its
670 kilometer long border with belarus
these are desperate people who have
become victims in a political conflict
far away from home their presence here
at this gateway into europe just shows
how vulnerable the strict eu stance on
asylum seekers and migrants has become
the eu has sent more than 100 border
troops and pledged 37 million euros to
help lithuania that usually only sees a
fraction of these arrivals to deal with
the crisis belarusian opposition leader
svetlana tejanovskaya who is living in
exile in lithuania urges the eu not to
give in to lukashenka
what a regime is doing is black mailing
european
with this immigration situation and
the answer should be even stronger you
can't be blackmailed by regime
the number of migrants arriving at the
border has decreased since iraq stopped
its flights to belarus but the situation
remains stands warning shots have been
heard from the belarusian site
stabfassen al jazeera vilnius lithuania